ukraine's president is appealing for
help to avert a catastrophe after his
government accused russian forces of
firing at europe's largest nuclear power
plant vladimir zelinsky says an
explosion would spell quote the end for
europe ukrainian officials say a fire
started at the zaparizia facility in the
south east after it was attacked by
russian forces the blaze is now under
control the international atomic energy
agency says essential equipment at the
plant hasn't
europeans please wake up tell your
politicians russian troops are shooting
at a nuclear power plant in ukraine
zaparizia nuclear power plant city of
there are six nuclear reactors there six
in chernobyl it was one reactor which
exploded only one
well the nuclear facilities near the
town of enagoda areas shaded red nearby
are controlled by russia and its
separatist allies al jazeera's natasha
butler joins us from levith in western
ukraine natasha so what more details are
emerging
about this fire at the zaparica nuclear
plant and how worrying is this
well what we understand from ukrainian
authorities is that that fire has now
been uh put under control by
firefighters but only after a very long
and uh difficult night now what happened
was in the early hours of the morning
here in ukraine there was a russian
attack on what we understand was a
generating unit within this power plant
and then ukrainian firefighters were
trying to get close enough to the plant
to put out a huge blaze that had broken
out but they were unable to do so at
first because uh ukrainian officials say
that they were being shot at uh by
russian troops they did eventually
manage to get close enough that blaze
has now been put out we understand that
the site is secured but of course there
has been a global condemnation for this
we've heard from world leaders including
the u.s president joe biden boris
johnson the prime minister of the uk but
of course uh the ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski accusing a russia of
using nuclear terror saying that if
anything was to happen to that power
plant we could be looking at effectively
something which would strike at the
whole of europe and not just ukraine and
cause uh devastation the ukrainian
foreign minister warning that if there
was to be a radiation leak from that
power plant which is europe's largest it
could be 10 times worse than the
chernobyl disaster yeah natasha and away
from that incident what more do we know
about this huge russian convoy that's
still heading towards key but doesn't
seem to be moving
well there's a lot of confusion over
what exactly is going on and what is
happening that convoy
60 kilometers long we understand
including armored vehicles uh tanks
refueling trucks
just doesn't seem to be moving and it
doesn't seem to have been moving now for
uh several days now us intelligence uh
officials some of them say that it is
not moving because of fuel problems fuel
supply problems uh food shortages that
the troops are unable to move forward
but it's it's something of a mystery
nobody seems to know but what we do know
is that convoy is within a shelling
distance of the capital uh keith so for
residents in the capital it must be
extremely difficult you can imagine
psychologically they are living in a
city they know they are pretty much
nearly surrounded by russian troops we
know they've been digging trenches
they've been trying to uh put food
supplies away they don't know what's
going to happen they don't know what the
intentions are of that convoy will it
move in
very difficult times for the people in
the capital and just a final uh thought
natasha just bring us up to date with
the latest in mario paul and any other
important locations across the country
in terms of the military picture on the
ground
sure well a very uh you know
across uk or ukraine another very
frightening difficult night for uh uh
people in in many parts of the country
particularly in those parts of the
country that are uh that are where
fighting has really intensified in the
south in the east mario paul you've
mentioned it there that key strategic
port on
the sea of azov well residents there and
ukrainian officials are saying it is
effectively a city under siege russian
shelling continuing there we've heard
also that water electricity heating has
all been cut there we are in the winter
here in ukraine it would be extremely
difficult extremely cold people huddled
in basements and then
in other places the city of kirsan on
the black sea another port that was
taken by uh russian troops on thursday
we also understand there the vital
supplies have been cut that they are
running out of medical supplies that
they are running out of food and that
shelling continues in kharkiv the center
of that city absolutely decimated in
rubble people there are effectively
trapped and that is why on thursday
ukrainian and russian officials in talks
well they certainly didn't come to any
conclusions about how to come to the end
of this conflict but what they did agree
on at least was possibly establishing
humanitarian corridors that could
evacuate civilians from some of these
key areas or get in uh key supplies
those are in desperate need because this
is a humanitarian disaster unfolding
natasha butler live for us there in live
in western ukraine natasha thank you
well tom